what's going on guys this is rob and i
want to cover the current run of the
eternals we're only about three issues
in and it's a monthly series so it's one
comic every month um so it'll probably
be kind of a slow going thing but the
story is really cool so far and i'm
curious to see how you guys would
respond to it uh but one of the things
this does is this basically opens up
with icarus essentially being revived
now to give you guys a little bit of
context here and this is exceedingly
important we go more in depth into this
in our eternals explained video so make
sure you check that out it'll be linked
down in the description but the whole
point behind this is that the eternals
originally believed that their modus
operandi right the reason why they
existed in the first place is because
the celestials had appeared on earth and
they had basically modified the genes of
early man and part of that modification
resulted in the eternals but the
eternals existed to basically kind of
safeguard humanity to guide humanity
because that was part of the celestial
experiment and the idea was that the
genes of a portion of early man had been
modified so that in the future they
would develop powers and so the eternals
essentially protected humanity from the
deviants and so that's why the eternals
of the deviants were always at war the
the thing that kind of leads into this
and the story that really kind of gives
us the explanation for why icarus is
being revived in the first place came in
all new all different avengers and this
was basically the revelation of the dark
celestials now that story built on a
previous story but the two kind of go
hand in hand and the the complete kind
of event that was given to us here was
that the reality of the eternal's
existence was to basically be like a lid
on a petri dish right the truth about
the celestial experiment was that every
planet they visit and every planet they
experiment on will be destroyed right
it's only a matter of time before it is
and the way this works is you have the
celestials and then you have the horde
and the celestials kind of represent
absolute good so to speak and that's a
loose term that i use but it's the
closest we get if we compare it to like
morality in comparison to what jack
kirby originally wanted to do with the
eternals in the old stories he did back
in 1976 and then the horde kind of
represent absolute evil and the energies
of both of these groups are fed on by
being called the fulcrum so the way this
works is that when an experiment is
conducted on a planet by the celestials
a portion of those genes are modified so
that at a future point in time they'll
develop powers hence the reason you get
mutants in marvel comics after some
predated amount of time which is
described as 19 cycles i don't know how
that how that compares to real world
time then what happens is the celestials
go back and then they basically harvest
the planet and if the energy of that
planet matches the energy signal of the
deviants then all the energy of that
planet goes to the horde which is just
kind of like an evil group that exists
out there if the energy of that planet
matches the energy of the eternals then
it goes to the celestials and so as a
way to kind of maintain this balance
between the celestials and the horde
quite literally they're vying for energy
based on a particular planet what this
meant is the eternals learned the truth
of their existence so they were
basically just kind of security guards
just keeping humanity safe so it could
be harvested at a future point in time
and even the eternals themselves would
be harvested at a future point in time
this basically led to the eternals going
insane and then killing each other right
they just went nuts like and some of
them committed suicide most of them just
took each other out but it was just like
this insane level of of existential
crises that they just couldn't handle
and so the result is it was marvel's way
of just kind of killing off all the
eternals just sort of striking them from
the entirety of the marvel landscape and
presumably doing so so they could reboot
them at a future point in time right
this was done less than a decade ago and
so i have to believe that marvel was
kind of gearing up for the possibility
of them doing an eternals film and just
kind of setting the stage so they could
bring them back adequately and that's
what happens here and so the result of
this is you end up having icarus who is
essentially kind of resurrected in
what's called the exclusion zone now the
exclusion zone serves a couple different
purposes in the eternals mythos the
first purpose is that when an eternal
dies if a resurrection is going to
happen they resurrect them there the
second thing is that it serves as a
prison so if there is an eternal that
defects from the cause right if the
eternals are there to protect humanity
and an eternal comes along and says no
we should enslave humanity and then like
goes on a campaign to kill as many
humans as they can they'll be locked
away in the exclusion and they'll be
left there until such a time as they
either repent and understand the error
of their ways and go forward as a proper
celestial or they'll stay there until
the end of all things right presumably
until like the world's destroyed or the
celestials call the eternals or whatever
the case happens to be in this instance
it's where icarus is being resurrected
now when he comes back he actually ends
up coming across xeros and xeros is now
currently the prime eternal and one of
the things they talk about here is the
idea of the one mind the one mind is
basically the unimined and kind of a a
quick synopsis or a quick explanation
again based on what we talked about in
our eternals explained video the unimine
is basically when the eternals come
together and quite literally combine
their minds and energy to create a
singular gestalt energy source that it
basically makes decisions it can also be
used as a weapon right like if a threat
is dire enough the unimine can be formed
which is like the collective energy of
all the eternals and is quite powerful
in its own right and so the decision was
more or less made because icarus is the
last person to return icarus was
previously the prime eternal or the
leader of the eternals because he was
the last to die he's the last to be
resurrected and that in that time frame
the unimined was formed and zuros was
chosen to be the leader now in my mind
it always should have been zuros who was
the prime eternal and the reason why is
because he's one of the oldest eternals
in existence and in fact i think him
outside of alars he is the oldest one
he's the oldest son of kronos but in
effect he's a second generation eternal
more or less and the reason why i say
that matters is because given the
history of the eternals if you guys
check out my video on the eternals
explain that we basically talked about
this idea that when they were first
created by the celestials that what you
had here was kronos and uranus and
uranus incited conflict he incited a
civil war against the eternals and then
in turn he incited a civil war among the
eternals which of course led to uranus
being defeated ultimately he was cast
off of earth and then eventually settled
on saturn's moon titan and then of
course there was a great big huge civil
war among those individuals but kronos
had two sons on earth the first was
zoros and the second was alars allars as
you guys know eventually went to uh
titan following the deaths of uranus and
his forces he married suisan they had a
couple kids one was eros also known as
star fox the other was dion also known
as thanos i never agreed with marvel
changing the name of thanos to dion but
the important thing here is that xerox
remained on earth and so as essentially
the oldest eternal he always should have
been the one to lead i think in the end
marvel basically chose icarus just
because of his popularity among comic
book readers but it makes sense that it
would be zoros here and so it's one of
those things that doesn't necessarily
sit well with icarus um but i think
again it's a good call because icarus is
kind of headstrong right he's very
brusque he's not much in the way of a
leadership style in terms of his
personality but at the end of the day
the choice was made and he simply has to
follow it and that's one of the things
that's established here when the unimine
makes a choice the choice is made and
that's it there's no arguing against
that if if icarus were to go to xeros
and say no you do not need to be the
leader of the eternals i should be the
leader of the eternals he'd be cast away
to the exclusion zone because in effect
he's committing heresy against the prime
eternal and so again it's just one of
those things that he just kind of has to
deal with now in the midst of that of
course as he's kind of traversing around
and figuring out what's going on here he
ends up coming across sprite this is one
of the funny things that marvel comics
did so the idea behind this is that
sprite was originally a guy marvel
switched him up to a girl i'm sure
there'll be comic book fans who are
going to be mad about it i don't really
know why it's not like they could give
me the history of sprite without looking
up a wikipedia article in the first
place so they're basically mad about
something they don't really know
anything about but at the end of the day
i think it's kind of a funny little
thing right it's kind of a cool little
maneuver and there's actually a reason
why this happens but the problem with
sprite is sprite is basically the
eternals version of loki
really what she is sprite causes
problems right sprite is just kind of a
prankster a trickster there was one
point where sprite actually wiped the
minds of all the eternals so it was kind
of nuts in terms of how all that
happened but that's kind of a cat and
mouse game that sprite always plays with
icarus and the other eternals which is
pulling pranks they track down sprite
sprite maybe gets a little bit of a
stern talking to you or a slap on the
wrist and it kind of goes on right it's
just sort of par for the course when it
comes to the character the biggest issue
with this is that as icarus is chasing
down sprite and kind of playing this
little little cat and mouse game sprite
teleports to new york city and when
sprite gets there suddenly everything is
brand new now a lot of this is because
of the fact that sprite has more or less
been backed up from a previous memory
that that sprite had the result of this
is that while sprite has experienced all
this before the idea of humanity in its
current form is known to sprite sprite
doesn't remember right just because of
the fact that again the memories that
she has here are from before she had
essentially encountered any of the
regular earthlings in their current form
and so by all standards of measurement
it's a whole new experience and it's
awesome
because sprite's like look at the things
that they've achieved this is awesome
you know this is cool but it's also kind
of icarus catching up sprite on a little
bit of her history and seeing like you
have kind of caused problems of the past
and like you literally tried to kill us
all now in the midst of this they're met
by the arrival of iron man and this is a
cool little moment here for a couple
different reasons one iron man and
icarus have met so many times of mobile
comics this is not a new thing right
it's not a brand new concept but it's
kind of cool because like iron man asks
like are you gonna freak out again and
again this ties into the deaths of the
eternals and the reason for that is
because with everything going on
regarding the dark celestials that iron
man and dr strange had actually sought
out the eternals because they regularly
commute with the celestials if there's
anyone on earth who's an authority on
the celestials it is the eternals right
they they know each other intimately and
so the results of this is that the last
time iron man saw icarus he was freaking
out and like all the eternals were
killing each other and so that's why
it's kind of like are you gonna kill
each other again you know is that is
that what's gonna happen you know it's
like no no we're good man
and so it's kind of a funny little thing
and so ultimately iron man is like okay
cool by the way man give my number to
cersei you know because like she's kind
of hot and it's it's weird right like
it's a little weird like iron man's
trying to get with a woman who's
something like like 10 000 years old or
something on those lines probably older
than that maybe closer to like 20 000.
we don't get a definitive date on how
old cersei is but like she's old now in
the midst of all this essentially excess
deviation is detected by icarus and the
result is he and sprite have to respond
to it now what's excess deviation so the
eternals are constantly at war with the
deviants they're always at war and it's
almost kind of like a internal alarm
system to a degree in the sense that if
deviants are in proximity eternals will
pick up on it and the eternals will go
and attack deviants but only under the
condition that deviants are essentially
doing what they're not supposed to be
doing in this instance a deviant
captured a human being under normal
circumstances the kind of rule the
unofficial world between the eternals of
the deviants is you stay away we stay
away right so you guys stay down there
in the underground and you do your thing
and we'll stay up here but as soon as
you guys step out of line boom we're
there right and we'll put you guys right
back in check again we'll kill whoever
we have to in the process and it's
almost kind of a sport right it's almost
one of these things where it's just kind
of like okay like you know this kind of
narrative that's given is like for
icarus it would be a fight right for
sprite it would be a game but for them
but because of something that they've
always done right like when when
deviants deviate eternal's correct it's
one of these things where it's like we
lust for the chance to fight deviants
right it's just what they do so like
that's one of the reasons why you kind
of noticed that the trickster nature of
of sprite suddenly vanishes and it's
like okay now it's time to kill some
deviants like it's a cool thing right
because ultimately they end up taking
this deviant out and they save the human
being and then they take him back to the
surface and of course they end up going
back to olympia now olympia is the
capital city and the reason why it's
called that because you would probably
immediately associate this with the the
greek god home of olympus this actually
happened in the very early days so the
eternals following their creation began
to come to the realization that gods
like zeus and hera athena apollo
aphrodite that they were basically
meddling in the affairs of humanity and
while the job of the eternals was to
essentially guide and protect humanity
with them realizing what was going on
there wasn't enough going on there for
them to like get involved in the sense
that like the greek gods weren't just
indiscriminately killing humans they
weren't really a credible threat to
humanity it was really more of them just
kind of getting involved in humanity
right so like zeus running around and
banging girls right and like aphrodite
banging dudes right that was essentially
it right and so they took a passing
curiosity eventually a kind of alliance
formed between the two groups if for no
other reason than the fact that one they
both operated on earth and two the
eternals wanted to keep a closer eye on
the greek gods eventually they became
more allies than enemies or anything
like that but it's one of these kind of
interesting instances where the eternals
sort of allied themselves more with one
group than another because you never
really saw the eternal spending a lot of
time on asgard and hanging out with like
odin and loki and thor and those kind of
guys largely because asgard's in his own
pocket dimension outside of earth so you
literally have to leave earth and travel
to a different dimension to get to it uh
but nonetheless it's one of these these
kind of interesting situations because
once they arrive there because sprite is
effectively meeting zoros for the very
first time or at least the first time
since uh sprites return it's kind of one
of those things of hey like make sure
you pay proper respect when you get to
the prime eternal the problem with this
is they come across fastos fastosos of
course being somebody who's not really a
pacifist but he's not really huge on war
but is really more just like the
technology guy the eternals who
essentially reveals that xeros has been
killed right somebody killed xeros they
effectively teleported in and teleported
out but the the crazy thing about this
is despite eternals being nearly
invulnerable and being exceedingly
difficult to kill somebody brushed the
head of of xerox with their bare hands
and that's why it's like okay who in the
hell did this right like who in the
world could have done this now at this
point you get to druid druid is just
kind of a dick and at one point was an
enemy of the eternals like their main
foe but it's one of these things where
initially the question is like could it
have been sprite but immediately people
are just kind of like no like one
sprite's not strong enough to do that
and two while sprite causes problems i
mean sprite wouldn't kill the prime
eternal would she
[Laughter]
but drury actually pinpoints directly to
icarus and it's like icarus was the
previous prime eternal and icarus last i
saw was none too happy about the fact
that the unimine determined that xeros
would be the new prime eternal this
guy's got motive he's got strength he's
got the ability to pull it off icarus at
that point just headbutts the hell out
of druid and it's just like that's
ridiculous and then effectively just
leaves now at this point it's on the
hunt for the person who did this right
and so what they end up doing is
basically teleporting to titanos the
fallen capital of the eternals now
titanos was the original capital of the
eternals that's why it's considered
fallen it's more or less been an
abandoned place but once they get there
there's this kind of hunting around
there's this almost kind of excess
deviation that's that's really felt by
icarus but not quite but at the end of
the day the question is okay this energy
source that we've traced to this
location who has an effect like
destroyed whatever eternals were left
here there has to be something going on
and ultimately you end up having this
kind of vision that's given to icarus of
some kid named toby robson who
ultimately ends up dying at 13 years old
and so it's kind of like who in the
world is this kid and the response of
icarus is i don't know this kid i've
never met this kid you know but at the
end of the day he's going to live i'm
going to save him and that's when you
get this kind of disembodied voice that
says more eternal blasphemy and a front
against the universe all that live must
die when i'm done there will be but a
single thing that is eternal and that
thing will be death the person who
teleported to the eternal base of
operations killed xeros then teleported
here to titanos and killed all the
remaining eternals here is thanos thanos
is literally gonna do everything he can
to wipe out every internal from
existence why he's gonna do that we
don't know
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are continuing on with our
story on the eternals there's a few
things that i want to clear up here yes
this bit of a battle does face or really
has like thanos facing off against the
eternals more icarus than the rest of
the eternals but it's a battle between
the eternals and thanos nonetheless uh
but i also want to kind of talk about
thanos and how he relates to the
eternals now i know a lot of you guys
who have been around my channel for a
long time already know this so kind of
bear with me for a minute because we got
a whole bunch of new subscribers with
the the icarus explained video that we
did and so on so thanos is in and of
himself an eternal but he's an eternal
with a deviant gene so depending on what
comic book fans you talk to some people
will say that he's just a deviant others
will say that he's an eternal with a
deviant gene and some will say he's a
hybrid of both the importance behind
this is that thanos is in some form or
fashion tied into the genetic makeup of
an eternal he was technically born to
both eternals he was born to suicide and
lars both of whom are pure eternals so
again it's one of those weird little
concepts the reality of this is that we
can really look at thanos more as like a
mutant among his own race in the same
way that like wolverine's considered a
mutant among the human race that thanos
is the same way that seemingly every
eternal has like a dormant deviant gene
but it just never seems to activate and
thanos is the unique exception among his
own people where being born with a
deviant gene that deviant gene was a
primary gene that deviant gene was
basically a dominant gene instead of a
recessive gene and that's why he looks
the way he does now thanos being a
member of the eternals is exceedingly
important and the reason why is because
thanos being able to travel through the
eternal gates by way of the machine is
something that can only truly be done by
a person who is of pure eternal blood
now a person who is not in eternal can
do it but they have to be given passage
by eternals essentially they have to be
given the key to open the doors by the
eternals themselves but the important
thing here is that with icarus having
shown up at basically the ruins of
titanos finding it more or less
destroyed and thanos occupying that
space the two of them get into a battle
now something that i want to stress here
this is the first time in marvel comics
that the eternals and really icarus
himself has actually fought thanos this
has never really happened before and so
in a lot of ways you're kind of talking
about what would normally be an even
battle between two characters but one
thing to keep in mind thanos is banned
from the realm of mistress death he is
effectively immortal and so because of
that he has everything he needs in order
to essentially survive whatever force he
faces off against now he's not immutable
and indestructible if his physical body
is incapable of surviving an experience
he'll more or less die that's one of
those instances where like drax the
destroyer comes into play right during
annihilation thanos was technically
banned from the realm of mistress death
but drax the destroyer was able to kill
him because it's a power imparted to
drax by the cosmic entity kronos that
drax can kill thanos so it almost kind
of triumphs or almost kind of trumps the
power of mistress death not officially
in the sense that when thanos was killed
his body simply ceased to function
because his heart was ripped out so
don't try to compare it one for one like
if iron man ripped out the heart of
thanos would he also stay dead in that
capacity this is one of those instances
when marvel just kind of cooks the books
for the purpose of telling a story so it
doesn't really apply universally across
the board it's what we call comic book
logic it's a plot device it just exists
to tell a story right so that's one of
the unique aspects of drax but the
important thing is the machine basically
opens a portal and then their fight
actually takes place through time now
while these two are fighting i want to
kind of explain the machine a little bit
so the machine as it's described to us
was given to us in eternals in 2006 but
there really isn't much in the way of
explanation regarding what the machine
is that is to say we don't know if it
was created by the eternals we don't
know if it was created by the celestials
to control the eternals we don't really
know or really have much information
behind it all we really know is the
machine is both itself a physical device
but it also represents the the system of
the eternals right their hierarchy how
it is that they exist the idea of
bringing people back from the dead
different things like that that's all
part and parcel to the machine and so
the machine itself is kind of a coming
together of smaller machines in the
sense that if you remember our last
video we talked about how there are
different tribes of eternals across the
world in the same way that you have like
different tribes of inhumans different
things along those lines while you have
eternals in different locations an
eternal in titanos can travel through
the gateway to an eternal and polaria
and much the same way with him going
vice versa and so it's smaller machines
that make all that possible and all
those small machines make up the larger
machines so again it's kind of weird
right it's like how all 50 states make
up the united states of america it's the
easiest way to understand that now the
important thing between the fight of
these two is that icarus was never going
to win the fight with thanos right that
was never going to happen and the reason
why is because icarus just doesn't have
the power to pull this off but at the
end of the day the fight between the two
is such that thanos overpowers icarus
and actually rips his head off only for
us to realize it was a construct created
by the machine but the reality of thanos
being able to pull this off is that one
thanos is temporarily incapacitated and
two icarus and sprite get out of there
as fast as they can because if thanos
gets his hands on the real icarus he'll
kill him right that's just the reality
of the situation that we're facing off
against is that thanos is just that much
more powerful than the eternals and so
following that icarus basically travels
to olympus right basically where the
eternals are currently residing and
meets with the rest of them and
effectively tells them thanos is here on
earth and thanos is the reason why all
this happened now i wouldn't go so far
as to say the eternals panic but they do
understand the threat of the situation
one of the other things they refer to
thanos as is the sin of titan during the
original thanos rising storyline and
even before that back in the day it was
kind of established by jim starlin
thanos effectively eradicated all of his
race on titan right that there were a
lot of eternals who lived there and
during his journey when he was
manipulated by mistress death he
actually left titan and then eventually
he came back with an army he had amassed
and eradicated everybody there it's
considered a unconscionable sin for
somebody for an eternal to basically
commit genocide against their own kind
to take out the entirety of the eternals
race or at least those eternals who
lived on uh lived on titan that was
unheard of under normal circumstances a
crime like that thanos would be locked
in the exclusion zone but there was no
one there to stop him right thanos was
of such a power to where nobody could
really stand against him and so that's
why he's considered to be the sin of
titan because thanos is the eternal who
went awry right he's the eternal he
became a bad guy blinked out half the
life in the universe during the original
infinity gauntlet story has done things
like that time and time again where he's
been a credible threat not just to earth
or even the eternals on titan but to the
universe as a whole and so because of
that the question becomes what are we
going to do here but the funny thing
about this is that while icarus pleads
with the eternals some of them don't
actually believe that thanos is here
that surely somebody would have noticed
that that was the case and so it's one
of these things where when icarus says
that thanos had actually traveled
through the eternal gates they kind of
say well thanos is not a true eternal
but the answer to that question is if
thanos is not a true eternal how is he
able to travel the eternal gates if
nobody gave him permission to do so and
so only one of two things is possible
here either we're basically looking at
marvel telling us thanos is really a
true eternal he just has the deviant
gene or the history of thanos is still
intact in the sense that because he had
the deviant gene it's like putting
iodine in a drop of water it permeates
and it kind of makes him an impure
eternal and not a true eternal which is
kind of what its history's sort of been
again depending on what comic book fan
you talk to and how marvel interprets
that the important thing here is that if
he's not necessarily a true eternal then
it means somebody let him in that means
that there's basically a spy among their
ranks or a traitor and somebody is
essentially letting him into this place
the other part of that is when they had
traveled to the exclusion zone in an
attempt to find out when zoros was going
to be resurrected due to the fact that
he's the prime eternal the news they get
is that all the wardens in the exclusion
zone are dead there's nobody there to
resurrect zoros and so in essence the
dead will stay dead this is exceedingly
important and the reason why is because
what it means is there's no resurrection
for the eternals that marvel as the if
the eternals start dying over the course
of the story marvel's effectively
thinning the herd if i'm a betting man
here the reason why marvel will be doing
this is because they're going to thin
the roster down so the comic book roster
matches the marvel cinematic universe
roster it's kind of what marvel comics
does now marvel follows the mcu as
opposed to the mcu following marvel but
again it's kind of an interesting
concept because in the midst of all that
while all this kind of accusation is
going on with regards to druid and kind
of pointing the finger at icarus and
saying hey man you've had time you've
had opportunity you know to to take out
xeros so that you could kind of take
your place back as the prime eternal
that's what you wanted to do maybe your
anger or jealousy that zoros replaced
you as the prime eternal whatever logic
makes sense to you and then you come to
us with the story about how the sin of
titan the mad titan himself thanos has
somehow made his way to earth with no
one knowing he's here and he's the one
behind it all what a convenient excuse
right what a convenient finger to point
that it's thanos that caused all this
and so cersei ultimately pops up and
says no right this is not gonna happen
even if there is some measure of truth
to what you're saying druid which
there's not but even if it was something
like icarus who did all this now is not
the time for eternals to turn against
eternals that's not what needs to happen
here the biggest problem with this that
you have is kind of a bit of an
emergency going on at the moment is the
machine is effectively failing that if a
portion of the machine is damaged then
the entire machine is damaged what's
kind of going on here is that by virtue
of thanos presumably thanos wiping out
all those wardens in the exclusion zone
and then destroying the portion of the
machine that deals with with
resurrecting uh eternals who have died
it's like pulling out the bottom piece
on a jenga set at the wrong time it's
only a matter before it all comes
crashing down and when that happens
because the machine is tied into the
biosphere of earth if the machine fails
the biosphere of earth fails basically
it becomes an uninhabitable planet this
i would say is something i can do a plot
device to a degree but not necessarily
at least that'd be kind of the throwaway
or the immediate response but the nature
of the eternals is that they are tied
irrevocably into the existence of the
earth itself and assuming the machine
was created by the celestials and left
here to control the eternals what better
way to do that than to tie the
habitability of the planet into the
machine itself right keep the machine
intact make sure it runs like it's
supposed to and you'll continue to
survive it's one of those interesting
concepts that marvel sort of throws in
there and so ultimately the questions
asked of the machine uh who did this
right like who gave thanos the ability
to travel here to earth by way of the
eternal gateways and the response of the
machine is i can find no data on the
exception i'm unable to remove that
exception in effect what it looks like
is again one of two things either thanos
is a true eternal and can travel from
one gateway to the other which they more
or less said that can't be the case or
there's somebody who allowed who made an
exception for thanos and then wipe that
exception from the database so once
thanos was here they removed the
exception and so as far as the machine
is concerned there was no exception and
so there's no exception to remove so in
essence if there is a traitor they snuck
thanos on board earth to wipe out the
rest of the eternals we don't
necessarily know who that person is or
why they would have done it at the
moment because the story follows icarus
there's really nothing he can do here
right i mean there is a little bit of
speculation that sprite might be
involved but nothing of any real
seriousness here and so at this point
it's really more of a whodunit mystery
who brought thanos to earth and why are
they allowing thanos to kill off all the
various eternals across the planet and
so what you end up doing is actually
traveling to new york to toby robson
because as we saw in the previous story
there was a kind of vision that icarus
got that toby robson had essentially
been killed and icarus saw it as a
failing of his now there is a kind of
motivation behind this which actually
sort of jumps back to a previous moment
in icarus's life when he had stumbled
across a man who kind of existed on an
island and basically asked him have you
seen a monster of course referring to
the deviants and when the answer the
remain of the man is i've never seen a
monster like that the only monster he
has is a kind of fish then he basically
tells him build up higher here and that
when a monster comes or when a deviant
comes light the pyre and then i will
respond but because of the fact that no
deviance came over the course of this
man's life this guy quite literally just
sat there waiting for monsters to show
up they never did and so he ended up
just kind of dying here now icarus
eventually showed up when the man was
basically buried by his family and the
pyre was lit in order to burn his body
and icarus thought a monster had been
summoned this is really kind of designed
to tie into the nature of icarus himself
this is one of the things that we
explained when we talked about his
character explanation and the video that
we did which you'll find down in the
description that icarus has lived for
countless eons and so what would be 90
years it's just a blink of an eye in his
life it might be minutes as far as his
mind comprehends it and so the result of
this is that when he tells the sky stay
here and light up higher so that if the
monsters ever return then i'll be here
to fight them that this man's life was
90 years for icarus it just felt like a
matter of minutes and so the people here
his family just scream and cuss at
icarus because of the fact that
basically this man wasted his life he
just sat there and just waited for
monsters to show up and they never did
but ultimately a giant deviant arrives
here and it really kind of shines into
sharp relief the fact that presumably
over the course of this man's life he
told them of the mission that was given
to him by what he perceived to be a god
and while they kind of wrote it off as
being nonsense and ridiculous in this
moment the man's words all hail supreme
but it's really a small comfort to his
family because at the end of the day he
still wasted his life right and so again
that seems to be why icarus is really
looking to protect toby robson the way
he is because it's more or less kind of
making amends for a previous failure
over the course of his life
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the eternals and the hunt
for thanos uh for those of you guys who
aren't really sure one check out parts
one and two down in the description i've
instructed my editors to start putting
the parts down there a lot of you guys
were asking about that and and that's
really kind of a mistake on my part
let's not include those so i've had my
guys start doing it um but uh parts one
and two will kind of get you guys caught
up but the important thing here is
basically somebody's been traveling
around and killing eternals right and
thanos made an appearance in both the
end of the first issue and in the second
issue where he fought icarus and the
idea was that thanos might be the person
behind it but the reality is they're
kind of hunting and and really looking
at a lot of different possibilities
because what it means is that if thanos
showed up on earth and thanos really is
the one responsible for doing it and
thanos was able to show up on earth
through the eternal gates that an
eternal had to have let him in in the
first place and so the first part of
this is finding the traitor then the
second one is trying to deal with thanos
but even for the eternals and the power
they possess it's no small feat to take
out thanos and in fact they can't really
even kill him the best they could do
would be to like find somebody to take
him into space lock him away in the kiln
and that would be it and that probably
wouldn't happen because the eternals
don't really operate in that way they
might end up just kind of locking them
away in the exclusion zone and that may
end up being it but what we end up doing
here is picking up with theena now thin
is an interesting member of the eternals
and there's a lot of cool history there
but she's actually woken up in the
lumeria city of the deviants now for
those of you guys who are kind of
unfamiliar with this i want to talk
about this for a minute for those of you
guys who are unfamiliar with the history
of the eternals and we don't need to go
into it all right well we'll i've got
videos that run over the origin of the
eternals and where they come from and
all that kind of stuff the idea behind
this was that before the deviants
attacked the celestials in the second
host that lumeria was the capital city
of the deviants and in a lot of ways it
was the capital of the world right
lumeria was a huge trading hub and so
those humans who were not enslaved by
the deviants would use lemuria as a way
to like trade goods and different things
like that it was a huge hub the result
of this is once the deviants had
attacked the celestials that the
celestials had sunk atlantis and the
capital city of lumeria and so the
result of this is this is one of the
last bastions of the deviants now as far
as how this equates to like the
atlanteans living on atlantis from what
i've seen in marvel comics over the
years and i haven't read every single
appearance of the deviant so don't quote
me on this but there more or less is
kind of like a loose sort of ceasefire
between the atlanteans and the deviants
in the sense that they just don't really
attack each other most of that's because
of the fact that if they ever went to
war that it would just be a slaughter on
both sides right the atlanteans are very
powerful but so are the deviants right
and it would literally just lead to an
outright massacre so it's one of those
kind of you stay away i stay away kind
of situations but the important thing
about this is that uh athena is suddenly
met by the arrival of cersei and the
other eternals who are here to kind of
question her about what's going on now
one of the big questions you're likely
asking yourself is that if fina and the
eternals are enemies of the deviants
then why she banging a deviant and we'll
actually answer that here in a minute
because there was a really cool story
that was created back in 1991 by roy
thomas called the eternals the herod
factor uh and it actually kind of
establishes a few things about them
which i think will be end up being kind
of a plot point when it comes to the
movie but the important thing here is
that athena as you as you imagine sounds
a lot like athena of greek mythology and
the reason for this is because back in
the early days of the eternals even
though they weren't necessarily gods
humanity believed them to be gods and so
the result is that usually whenever you
read marvel it's kind of a consistent
statement among the eternals that
humanity confused them for god's but
because of the fact that eternals were
designed to safeguard humanity and when
they went back to you know undertaking
that role after the second celestial
host and the the almost wholesale
slaughter of the deviants that the
eternal started watching what was going
on around the earth and when you ended
up having like the the olympian gods
right so like zeus and and hercules and
uh hera and athena and all them when
they started getting involved in the
affairs of men the eternals took
interest in it and so what ended up
happening is a kind of pact was struck
between the eternals and the olympian
gods where they where it was more or
less like the eternals would operate as
quote unquote the agents of the
olympians on earth and so because athena
at that point was known as azura and she
was believed to be athena that this
basically resulted in people calling her
athena and so that's one of the
instances where a kind of confusion was
struck between humanity and the various
gods that existed but the important
thing here is that the the whole reason
why they're kind of asking this question
is because normally eternals don't spend
time with the deviants right it's just
it doesn't work that way like they're
enemies and so what ended up happening
here is after azura was reborn much in
the same way icarus was that she had she
had traveled to essentially visit her
father and the idea is that she wanted
to quote unquote make the make the
deviants better in the sense that she
didn't really want to be enemies with
them anymore that instead it was kind of
like we can work alongside them and we
can make them better people her father
of course was like no and as one of the
original eternals or i guess maybe the
the first member of the second
generation of eternal so the son of one
of the original eternals that wasn't
going to happen right xeros was just
avidly against that right he's like no
no the deviants are enemies they stay
enemies like we kill deviants deviants
kill eternals that's just the way that
it is right we don't mix like that it's
just that's not how things are supposed
to be but ultimately athena was like no
and then she made this kind of
off-handed comment like i'll kill you
father and you would be better off dead
and so because of that statement even
though it was kind of an idol threat and
there really wouldn't be an instance
where athena would seemingly kill her
dad the result is that it led the
eternals to question this right to ask
are you the one who killed zoros and
that's what it's kind of really brought
for the first time to the attention of
athena that oh my god zuros is dead and
so following that you jump directly over
to icarus right now this little this is
kind of a subplot for icarus and kind of
showing what's going on with him this
was par for the course when it comes to
the eternal story so those of you guys
who are curious about this it's par for
the course and that's one of the reasons
why kieran gillan's run is so cool
because it really falls rank and file
with like the old roy thomas stuff right
it just you know even like the old jack
kirby stuff it just falls almost
perfectly in line icarus was far and
away the most popular of the eternals
because he had the most going on with
the regular mortal world and so to see
him more or less doing the same thing
here it's just classic eternal
storytelling it's got a different face
on it and it's got a little bit you know
the art is certainly better than the old
eternal stuff i know you old school jack
kirby fans are going to be pissed but i
gotta say
i prefer eastside rubick over jack kirby
but uh but nonetheless you know it's one
of these things where he's actually here
because if you guys recall in the last
video that we did that toby robson was a
vision that icarus saw where it was i
need to keep this kid protected and
again one of the things we talked about
was that with icarus's history in marvel
comics from his character's standpoint
there's been a lot of failings on his
behalf right that the the biggest
failing is really like the eternals not
really safeguarding humanity the way
they were supposed to originally hence
the reason why humanity in its early
days was enslaved by the deviants now
for the most part icarus wasn't really
around at that exact point in time there
wasn't really anything he could do at
that exact point in time but the
important thing here is that with the
second celestial host and everything
just kind of popping off that following
that the eternals underwent the role
they were supposed to and icarus was a
part of that aftermath and so with that
being the case one of the things that we
talked about in a previous video as well
is that because his lifespan is so long
and because he doesn't really grasp what
it means to tell a mortal a particular
thing that may take up years of their
life that in this instance he had told a
person stay here and watch for monsters
and when a monster comes then light the
pyre and because the early days of
humanity was such that they confused the
eternals for gods this guy felt like it
was a command that he was given by a god
and he was gonna follow it and so he
basically wasted his whole life but
icarus saw that and realized okay you
know for me i'm basically immortal i
will essentially live forever and even
if i die i will be i'll be resurrected
i'll come back the important thing here
is is that for icarus kind of looking at
all this the idea of basically guarding
toby robinson from a potential death
that he saw based on his vision is
really not him protecting toby because
toby has any real value it's even stated
here he doesn't know what the importance
of toby is he's doing it because he's
trying to make up for past misdeeds and
that's kind of an important thing when
it comes to icarus and it's one of the
things that made icarus so interesting
even if the eternals themselves as a
whole were not necessarily that
interesting is because it was really his
involvement and his desire to make up
for past sense right for mistakes that
he'd made in the past to try to fix
those retroactively by doing the right
thing now it's one of the things we
talked about with icarus explained he
took the name icarus after his son
because his son died and so long as he
has this name his son will seemingly
live forever so it's that kind of theme
that goes on and on with his character
and so following this you have fina who
actually communicates with the machine
right we talked about that in the
previous video this kind of complex
machine based system that we don't
really know much about whether it was
created by the celestials the eternals
or what have you but essentially
communes with it and realizes one part
the the resurrection system of the
machine was destroyed and the two zoros
really is dead and so those eternals who
die there's seemingly no way to bring
them back and so following this you have
this kind of discussion and even a
little bit of of conversation between
fina and cersei and of a bit of a
flashback from about a hundred thousand
years ago and the way this plays out is
you end up finding out that fina had at
one point been in a relationship with uh
with a deviant by the name of zygo and
there's this kind of thing where she
says that zygo is not like crow now the
important thing here and again this goes
back to the herod's storyline the herod
factor from roy thomas is that most of
you guys know crow is kind of like the
warlord right the the general who led
the deviants that he and then were in a
relationship at one time and they kind
of end up getting back together knowing
that it wasn't necessarily going to work
but athena has seemingly always kind of
had a thing for deviants right now it's
not as omaha comics paints the picture
that she likes bad boys but it's one of
these things where she seemed to always
kind of have this desire to like make
the deviants better right to improve the
deviants the reality is that they're a
culture with a with a half measure of a
dna system right so every generation
lives a shorter life span than the
generation before it right it's just one
of those things where it just kind of
falls apart as the generations go on and
so because of that you can't really fix
the deviants per se you can't make them
better it's it's quite literally baked
into their genealogy you might be able
to find a few here and there who will
break off and become good guys but for
the most part they're always kind of
twisted and so the result of this is
that with theena kind of being in love
with zygo and having a relationship with
him she's almost kind of blind to this
idea that like deviants are deviants and
you can't change their way it's just how
they are they will use you for whatever
ends they can but at the end of the day
their heart is built on the foundation
of destruction and torture and pain and
torment it's all they know it's what
they were bred to be this is how they
it's how they are and so in order to
prove this point what you end up having
is uh is is cersei who takes thena to
this kind of hidden base right this kind
of hidden area that zygo was using and
come to find out what he'd been doing is
harvesting the organs of other deviants
and even other other beings out there in
the mortal world for the purpose of
trying to make himself into an eternal
and it's one of these things where
cersei says like you can't fix them
right like no matter what you do at the
end of the day he doesn't necessarily
see you as anything special he sees you
as a means to an end his desire is to
perfect the process of turning somebody
into an eternal and then when the time
comes he was gonna kill you and he was
gonna harvest your organs and he was
gonna make you make himself into one of
us and use you to do it and with that
kind of betrayal of the heart coming
into play and fina realizing that there
is no way right that like zygo had to
die but like there is no way to to make
them better she kind of abandons this
idea of ever loving a deviant right of
ever being in love with a demon we of
course no that's not the case but kind
of jumping back to the modern day this
is designed to sort of show the struggle
that phoenix had over the course of her
entire life span but two the kind of
animosity that exists between the two
and that's an important thing to
understand here because if you look at
the eternals with a kind of cursory
glance they're essentially a band of
individuals with incredible powers and
they kind of hang out and do some stuff
and for the most part all's all's quiet
on the western front now there's a lot
of infighting there right i mean when
you've lived for a hundred thousand
years you're bound to have a few
disagreements
you're bound to have a few a few
skirmishes between you and other people
and that's one of the things where it's
kind of like i mean yeah they all sort
of exist but like in a lot of ways they
don't necessarily like each other but
they stand in unison because they kind
of have to but it's one of the things
where athena kind of looks at everything
that's going on and been like it's kind
of like look the the the fourth
celestial host the final celestial host
came and went a long time ago right like
that's what killed us is we learned from
the final celestial host that we were
just here to to more or less safeguard
humanity so they could be you know
fodder more or less so that the
celestials could destroy the world and
then like whatever the energy signature
of earth was would go to the horde right
now i know we've kind of talked about
the horde before for those of you guys
who are curious we can make a video
about that if you want me to right i can
explain like the horde the eternals all
that kind of stuff i can make sense of
all that let me know that's something
you guys are interested in but the
overall gist is at least as far as thena
goes is we don't owe anything to the
celestials anymore and so come to find
out what ends up happening here is druid
it's basically contacted by cersei or at
least he contacts her and kind of asks
like are you alone and she's like i mean
i'm here with eternals but like they
can't necessarily hear what i'm saying
and he ends up saying that like he'd
return to paleria right to receive
orders from the supreme falcon now a
little bit of history here right to give
you guys some context even before the
eternals had kind of like abandoned
their role of safeguarding humanity and
then were ultimately forced to after the
second celestial host when the eternals
first began to sort of emerge after the
celestial modification of human genes
they actually spread across the world in
different factions and this is why you
have the celestial machine that has
different locations across the world and
so while you had eternals in olympia
which was kind of like their capital
city so to speak you also had eternals
in polaria now it's not as though the
eternals and polaria completely ignored
eternals in an olympia they were aware
of the others existence and they would
cross over if they needed to right like
they would come to the aid of others it
was just one of those where it was just
like different people living in
different locations and so the result of
this is that during the second celestial
host what had happened is you had irish
and the judge who had shown up on earth
along with a host of the celestials to
judge it right and then you had the
deviants who would attack the celestials
and so what ended up happening here is
you had uh one of the celestials who
actually wanted to cleanse the entirety
of the world believing that the entire
process of modifying human genes had
more or less been a failure irish and
the judge blocked the order and the
assumption was that eris and the judge
was screwing up and the reason why was
because the celestials operated in such
a capacity so that once they made a
decision it was kind of unified right
and the idea was if an experiment was
deemed to be a failure they would just
cleanse the whole world it's how they'd
done it on a multitude of different
planets the fact that the earth was
being treated as an exception seemed
like an error in their programming as it
had been designed by the fulcrum and so
when this one celestial stepped in and
tried to effectively destroy irish and
the judge that celestial was cast out
right it was basically defeated and then
it was left on earth and then in turn
all the the very essence and the
technology and all the means by which a
person could effectively weaponize or
resurrect that celestial was put in the
hands of falcon now as most of you guys
know or have probably guessed by now
that particular celestial was tiamu the
dreaming celestial and that's how that
was how it was basically locked away on
earth which is why you're likely going
to see the dreaming celestial in the
eternals film i don't know if you are
i'm assuming you are but again whoever
it is it's going through presumably
thanos and killing all these different
eternals had landed in paleria and they
killed every single one of the eternals
on paleria as well which includes falcon
the assumption here is that now at this
point the leader of the eternals falls
directly on druid and the reason for
that is because druid is part of is
basically an heir to the throne of
polaria and so now the assumption is if
all those eternals have been killed in
that location was druid the one who did
it so again it's one of these things
where it just kind of bounces around
from person to person to person we
ultimately know that thanos seems to be
the one to have done all this but is it
druid or somebody else who's enabling
thanos and actually pointing him in the
direction of these different locations
and taking them all out
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the eternals now here's
the funny thing about this one of the
big on running theories about the
eternals in the marvel cinematic
universe is that they're basically
robots who are designed to serve a
purpose and that now that the earth has
superheroes that their purpose is
effectively served and there's not
really a need for them anymore this
story is going to kind of confirm that a
little bit but sort of in the way that
you don't expect but for those of you
guys who are are really unfamiliar with
this and we kind of talked about this a
little bit the eternals had been dead
for quite some time and that the machine
which is a relatively new invention in
marvel comics had basically begun the
process of resurrecting them in the
exclusion zone now the exclusion zone is
a long-standing concept right it's how
the eternals usually always end up
coming back but we didn't really know
who was killing the eternals but we
largely believed it was thanos because
thanos has just kind of been here
popping in and out and then there's just
been kind of like these bodies of
eternals sort of laying in his wake and
the big question is if it really is
thanos who's killing the eternals why is
it just some basic motivation that
thanos harbors a vendetta against the
eternals he is basically an eternal
himself with a deviant gene albeit from
a different sect in the same capacity
that like people in africa are humans
but they don't share american culture so
the kind of question is why would he be
going after these guys right what's the
motivation for hunting after him the
other part of this is that the eternals
usually always existed in isolation
although occasionally they would cross
over with other superheroes and events
like the onslaught saga maybe secret
wars or something along those lines you
never really saw them you know really
get involved in the affairs of mortal
men for cersei herself her big question
here is to kind of get involved with
tony stark to find out what the avengers
know to find out if there's any
information they have that she can
gather because one of the biggest things
to know is that with iron man having
previously become aware of the fact that
the eternals have basically returned now
it's going to turn into iron man if for
no other reason than his own curiosity
exploring what's going on in the world
with regards to the eternals right so
the avengers may have done their own
investigation you know iron man mr uh mr
fantastic at the fantastic four reed
richards they may have done their own
thing so the idea of cersei is to get
what information they can from them see
if she can't apply it to her own
information and then come to a stronger
conclusion the other part of this is
again the character of toby now toby is
this person that icarus who's kind of
like the main hero of the eternals had
this premonition about that he was
ultimately going to die and the goal of
icarus is to save toby right to kind of
keep toby alive of course with
everything popping off what icarus had
done is he had tasked sprite with
keeping an eye on toby making basically
making sure that toby's protected by
whatever threats happen to be out there
and that if the time comes when a threat
does emerge for example thanos showing
up and trying to attack toby that sprite
would hold off the force of thanos as
best as she possibly could and then
alert icarus who of course would return
and try to understand what's going on
here and so what you end up getting is
this interesting scenario where a lot of
it comes down to druid now druid is
is kind of interesting when it comes to
the eternals the reason why i say that
is in the past he's largely been a main
enemy of the eternals but it's one of
these things where because of the fact
that different eternals are being
attacked right eternals and polaria who
are not necessarily enemies of eternals
in olympia but the two groups don't get
along uh because of the fact that
eternals are being attacked basically
across the board regardless of what
faction they're from then it's kind of
like okay all hands on deck everybody
band together and druid trying to
understand what's going on but make no
mistake druid's very similar to like
loki in the eternals mythos in the sense
that yeah he's kind of working with the
good guys but he usually has his own
ambitions his own goals and drives and
he really gets emerged and like
subterfuge things like that and that's
why when he is approached by like fina
and all these eternals here that are
kind of questioning whether or not he
had a hand in this the fact that the
polaria eternals are dead that he was a
servant of them and so if he's looking
to essentially begin the process of
wiping out quote unquote all the
competition whatever his motivation
happens to be why not start there and
then work his way out into other
eternals then ultimately they kind of
come to the realization they didn't have
a hand in it right there's nothing about
this that he had any involvement in and
the reason they know that is because
thanos appears and thanos starts
crushing all of them and that's the
important thing to get here right when
it comes to thanos he is intriguing in
relation to the eternals the eternals
themselves are already hugely powerful
right thanos is like a mutant among his
own eternal race meaning he's more
powerful than the other eternals and so
thanos showing up here and facing off
against these guys it shows there's not
really a whole lot they can do right
they face off against him as best they
can but thanos is just too overwhelming
and too powerful now this comes from a
combination of different things one it's
the physiology of thanos his durability
strength speed stamina all that kind of
stuff but also the enhancements he's
made to himself technological
modifications as well as you know gifted
enhancements that were given to him by
mistress death right some measure of
immortality or kind of definitive
immortality although recently he's
basically died and you know somehow he
managed to come back here different
things along those lines the only real
savior they have here comes in the
momentary action of druid who uses his
telepathy to kind of lock thanos inside
of his own mind and you get this amazing
moment right where thanos is like really
like i've mashed wits against cosmic
beings right and he has thanos has gone
toe to toe with like galactus silver
surfer people whose telepathic powers
are well beyond that of druid and the
eternals and he's like you really
believe that this little trick will
somehow stop me and the response of
druid is no but it'll delay you
sufficiently enough to where other
eternals can arrive and then we can all
take you down and he's like that's
ridiculous like i have i've held the
power of the infinity gauntlet in my
hand and wiped out half the life in the
universe i promise you i can easily
overcome you and ultimately while thanos
does get his hands on druid and in the
moment goes to kill him all these other
eternal starts showing up and thanos
does the only thing he can do which is
basically teleport away but this
essentially frees druid of any suspicion
right that thanos is going around and
killing different eternals his next
targets were these guys right here and
druid effectively saved the day and so
what you end up getting here is thina
basically saying like we have to get
icarus we have to go after the forgotten
one we have to go after gilgamesh now
the idea referring to gilgamesh as the
forgotten one who leads the forgotten is
really intriguing here and this is
kieran gillan kind of building on some
of the concepts of the eternals over the
years and then making some modifications
of his own right gilgamesh is one of the
eternals who's been around for an
exceedingly long time but unlike a lot
of the other eternals who kind of
adopted their own names as time went on
gilgamesh didn't necessarily do so he's
really adopted multiple names over the
course of his existence the big
difference here and the reason why you
kind of have them referred to as the
forgotten we'll talk about here in a
second but before we do i want to switch
back over to druik for a second because
what we end up having is druik by
himself and then a portal opens up
behind him only for thanos to reemerge
and that's when we find out that while
thanos is not necessarily the one who's
killing eternals at the behest of druid
then again much like we would expect
from characters like loki where a lot of
these guys who engage in subterfuge and
have their own agendas that druid is
much the same way that drug instead
basically asked thanos i mean yeah sure
there's a traitor among our ranks the
big question to ask here is why wouldn't
you come to me if anybody's best suited
to betray the eternals and to help you
carry about this mission of destroying
the eternals it would be me i'm the best
person suited for that so let's work
together and see what we can work out
now following that you switch over to
cersei meeting with tony stark and this
is kind of a funny thing because as the
two of them are talking one of the
things that she had mentioned to fostos
uh you know really when they were kind
of talking before she before she'd come
here was that tony stark's easily
manipulated and that's true tony stark's
had a thing for cersei for a long long
time but also understanding tony stark
the way that she does she's like i mean
this guy's ego and his lust are like the
two big things that rule him right
everything else is secondary so it's
very easy to take advantage of that
right she's like i'll basically you know
like manipulate him a little bit i will
seduce him and then i'll try to find out
you know what he knows about the other
avengers or information they have that
can help us with this goal of trying to
figure out uh you know what's going on
with this machine or or what have you
who's killing eternals and then we'll
basically call it a day right the funny
thing here is that of course using her
powers she ends up effectively shutting
down the nervous system of tony stark
and then just kind of says like you know
i have to make a few edits here and kind
of makes a statement and saying thanos
has been killing my fellow eternals
thanos is behind the destruction of the
machine and thanos will rule the earth
when i'm done and then suddenly she's
attacked by the forgotten one right the
forgotten one just comes out of nowhere
and immediately goes after cersei now of
course icarus shows up just in the nick
of time you know when she says like
icarus now i need you icarus arrives
here and then basically offers a
distraction and starts facing off
against the forgotten one only for us to
find out that what cersei had done by
basically manipulating the nervous
system of tony stark tony stark heard
her say thanos has been killing my
fellow eternals the analysis behind the
destruction of the machine yada yada
that what the forgotten one heard is i'm
the one who killing who's killing
eternals i'm the one behind the
destruction of the machine and so
ultimately this is what drew him out and
it was all really a ruse right it was
the only real way to get the forgotten
one to show up here because a forgotten
one doesn't just show up out of nowhere
more specifically than that the question
they all that always kind of had to be
asked here is if the eternals are there
to safeguard humanity then who watches
the watchmen right who watches the
eternals and that's what the forgotten
dude the forgotten are kind of like the
police of the eternals to a degree where
they've kind of taken it among
themselves to ensure that if there are
any eternals that abuse their power in
relation to humanity try to force them
into subservience different things like
that in the same way the deviants did in
the early days of human history that the
forgotten would kill those eternals they
would destroy them right because they
deviate from their purpose and so the
forgotten one gilgamesh kind of
overhearing cersei saying i'm the one
who's killing eternals i'm the one who's
responsible for the destruction of the
machine means that's my target right so
that's why he went after cersei now of
course once everything kind of calms
down between the forgotten and between
icarus then it's kind of a conversation
point right then it's a talking point
right it's kind of like okay let's kind
of figure out what's happening and
what's going on here the funny thing
about this is that because the
motivations and really the purpose of
the forgotten are to keep the eternals
in check then if their goal is to kill
eternals that basically deviate from
their roles they're the next best
suspect here right if somebody's going
around killing eternals then maybe it's
the forgotten and the forgotten one
right gilgamesh maybe he's the one
that's doing it right like it's
literally i mean at this point it's
turned into a witch hunt is really all
it is right the is a gigantic witch hunt
just going after people arbitrarily
because they satisfy whatever motivation
uh needs to be satisfied for why the
eternals think things are happening and
so that's what's what's going on here
right going after gilgamesh the
forgotten all those guys it's kind of
like you guys kill eternals right you
guys are there are the ones who are
responsible for the for the deaths of
various versions of us why wouldn't you
be doing it now and if you are why
what's your motivation what have we of
the eternals done to basically bring
this wrath that you have to wipe out so
many of us what's the point and the
response to the forgotten is it's not us
we're not the ones who are killing you
guys we're not the ones who are
destroying you guys that's not our goal
and our motivation like that's that's
not the case like somebody else has a
hand here somebody else is involved here
in doing these things right so stop
blaming us the big kicker about all this
is that when they take him to to really
an aspect of the machine that the
forgotten one kind of goes through right
gilgamesh starts going through and
analyzing and saying yeah like it's been
sabotaged like any scientist of note
would have found this just by looking at
it right i mean i even told fostos how
to how to sabotage the machine the whole
entire time this has been going on
vastos has no idea how any of this
happened fostos is like i don't know
what's going on with the machine i don't
know how it's been sabotaged but
supposedly he's been working on the
machine trying to fix it the entire time
the reality is he's been trying to
destroy it right and that's the thing
like fostos is just gaining the trust of
the eternals that's all it is right just
kind of building on that trust aspect
because he's the most loyal he's a
pacifist he doesn't like war he doesn't
like conflict he doesn't like to to get
involved in massive affairs like this so
fostos being the one behind what is in
effect the deaths of all these eternals
takes all the other eternals by surprise
right it just it blows them away and
then of course fostos makes contact with
thanos and says like like there's people
coming to the exclusion they'll be
they'll get here fast you have to stop
them you have to let me continue my work
now the question becomes why is thanos
working with fostos right like why why
are these two guys teaming up they're
enemies right thanos is considered the
sin of the eternals no eternal would
willingly work with thanos so why in the
world are they working together here and
so ultimately what you end up finding
out is the main goal in the destruction
of the machine by fostos is to destroy
the eternals but it's not to destroy the
earth but keep in mind one of the things
that we talked about in a previous video
is that while we don't have a whole lot
of history about the nature of the
machine in fact we don't really know
anything about it what we know is that
the machine is tied to the earth so if
the machine is destroyed the earth will
be destroyed fostos doesn't seem to know
this it just seems to be from his
perspective that the eternals themselves
are tied to the machine that by
destroying the machine that destroys the
eternal's ability to resurrect and then
from there it's just using thanos to
destroy what remains of the eternals and
there's no way for the eternals to come
back so why wipe out the entire eternal
race switch over to one month earlier
when thanos is basically brought back by
fostos and what he basically says is
like you work for me now right like i
have found a way to bring you back but
this body is not a permanent body this
is a temporary body but understand if
you basically fulfill these tasks as i'm
assigning them to you then i will bring
you back right i will i will resurrect
you properly and you'll actually be back
in your full form with your full power
if you deviate against me if you violate
any of the policies that i'm giving you
if you work against me then i will
destroy you i will make sure that the
body that you inhabit dies and you'll
never ever come back again and that's
why thanos is working for fostos because
thanos of course seeks to return to life
it was always one of the contradictory
aspects of thanos for a person who is so
incredibly in love with mistress death
and is a complete and total nihilist who
believes that life is meaningless and
death is the only real valuable
commodity that exists out there why is
he always hankering to come back to life
why is he always hankering to return it
was one of those things that didn't
really make a whole lot of sense you
would think that a guy who's obsessed
with mistress death would just off
himself right and just be like i'm gonna
kill myself so i can stay with mr steph
a lot of that seems to be predicated on
the events of infinity gauntlet which
solidified this idea that thanos would
go as far as to wipe out half the life
in the universe to gain the affection of
mistress death that in the fact that
he's so popular nobody wants to see him
dead they want to see him alive they
want to see stories with him so you kind
of end up having to do that because how
interesting could a story about thanos
be if he's just standing around with
mistress death in the afterlife not
doing anything while this whole great
big huge fight is going on between
thanos and the eternals they're doing
everything they can to face off against
them and they're doing it quite well
right that's one of the funny things is
that as powerful as thanos is one-on-one
with most any eternal he's gonna
overcome them but given the wide and
varying powers that the eternals have
when they work in unison and they come
together albeit without the unimine that
thanos is it's a difficult task for him
to overcome all of them especially
somebody like cersei who has the power
of trans modification right matter
manipulation it's one of these things
where it's not easy to overcome that
especially when she can use it to modify
the body of thanos and to cause all
kinds of problems with him now thanos's
healing factor his durability his
strength and just his general
wherewithal right his drive to succeed
is oftentimes what allows him to
overcome the eternals right that he's
just so single-minded to a task it's
wildly difficult to overcome that the
problem and the one thing that fostos
didn't account for is that as he begins
the process of destroying the machine
that the machine doesn't hold as well as
he thought he would and basically the
beginning of the end of the world starts
and so what ends up happening is that as
everything starts falling apart then
suddenly the machine does it kind of
serves its purpose where it basically
teleports everybody all over the world
that the machine itself is going awry
it's not supposed to function that way
the machine's broken right it's like if
your computer gets a virus i guess and
just starts spitting pop-ups right it's
not functioning the way that it's
supposed to doesn't work as intended and
so the results of this is that icarus
gets to the machine as fast as he
possibly can and then suddenly where you
end up having fossos who tries to offer
some insight to uh to icarus on how to
fix things that ultimately you have
druid who pops up and then modifies the
mind of fostos and so basically this is
designed to ensure that whatever fausto
says will not be taken seriously there's
a secret that he holds that he intends
to spill to the rest of the eternals and
that that druid doesn't want anybody to
actually know what's going on or
seemingly that's the case now of course
the actions of icarus of course work and
basically keeping the machine contained
right keeping the machine controlled and
then in turn ensuring that everything
kind of goes back to normal and the
world doesn't end right which is pretty
straightforward then attention turns to
fostos right what's going on here now
that's where things are intriguing
because the the ultimate goal here of
druid is that at the end of the day was
to keep thanos alive right that's what
kind of goes on here i mean sure it was
the secret that fostos harbors but
keeping thanos alive was another part of
this and that's why with thanos being
here and them realizing that he was the
one who brought thanos back it's like no
no to destroy thanos all i have to do is
just activate the thing inside his body
but before he can finish this he
realizes he can't remember how to stop
thanos he can't remember how to kill
thanos and so in effect druid has
solidified thanos full return to the
marvel universe or at least that seems
to be the case anyway most likely in a
more stripped down version in terms of
power than what we're used to to kind of
bring him further in line with the
marvel cinematic universe but we don't
definitively know that right we don't
definitively know if that's the case
because even thanos's current form is
left kind of ambiguous in the sense that
last we saw him he had kind of been
defeated by cersei and was just like in
this sort of bubbly weird looking form
and that was basically it it seemed as
though his physical form had been
destroyed but again we don't
definitively know of course we'll find
out here in the next story arc the big
secret that fossos is hiding though is
the nature of the eternals the cost of
their immortality this is a really
really cool aspect of the eternals
mythos that with thanos having been
defeated what fosdos basically reveals
here is that as far as the eternals are
concerned that whenever they die the
machine resurrects them right they go to
the they're kind of reborn in the
exclusion zone they're given a given uh
i guess a duplicate of their previous
body and they're resurrected in that
body but there is a cost to immortality
the cost of this is that where icarus
had sacrificed his life to preserve the
machine the machine does resurrect him
and toby dies the person he was supposed
to save ends up perishing that's the
cost of resurrection every time an
eternal comes back to life a human dies
every single time without fail it's just
the cost of eternal immortality and so
in effect they are designed to save
humanity while at the same time
consuming humanity each time they're
resurrected why the machine works this
way we don't know that's again that's
the nature of the machine we don't
really know definitively who designed it
this way presumably the celestials did
but it seems kind of weird the
celestials would task the eternals with
safeguarding humanity and then at the
same time cost humanity every time the
eternals are resurrected right it's kind
of a weird thing there but at the end of
the day zeros of course is brought back
and of course that leads to the death of
a human the eternals also come to grips
with that in saying at least as far as
they're concerned and the kind of
statement they give to xeros is yes we
accept that right like we accept the
fact that this is just the role we play
this is the nature of things but that's
the big struggle when it comes to cersei
when it comes to icarus when it comes to
fina in these guys is well we'll bring
the unimine together and we'll convince
the eternals the rest of the eternals to
understand this is the price of
immortality but the response is kind of
given here by cersei is they don't care
nobody else is going to care at the end
of the day the response they the whole
belief they have xeros and everybody
else is that humanity is beneath them
and so while they wouldn't necessarily
let humanity succumb to this to their
destruction at the hands of the deviants
lest the eternals face the wrath of the
celestials that they're not gonna go out
of their way to protect humanity from
like themselves or anything like that so
it's kind of sitting on this this sort
of borderline between letting humanity
destroy themselves allowing humanity to
be sacrificed and seeing themselves as
being more important than humanity and
so the way you know this kind of being
perceived as the way the eternals is
really more of a ruse by icarus and all
these guys and what they end up doing is
actually going to the capital city of
lumeria the home of the deviants they're
really their greatest enemy and in turn
they say like we come in peace to the
changing people we have no desire to
wage a war with you guys instead we want
to join you help us be the changing
people too in essence icarus and this
core group of eternals are turning
against the other eternals and the
intention here is to join the deviants
presumably to bring the downfall of all
the eternals in essence they seem to
have bought in and understood the the
goal and the motivations of what fossos
was doing and they've essentially come
to this realization that the the price
that that's paid for immortality is
simply just too high they're not willing
to sacrifice innocent human lives to
preserve their own lives but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end i love this eternals run
by kieran gillen it's fantastic it's
really a more of a cerebral story right
it's really more of a thinking story as
opposed to like a single action-packed
story but i love the way it's done let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments and i will catch you all later
peace
you